so thanks so much for coming down to my
house thanks for having me samuel how
long have you been in property now then
only five months five months yeah so
what happened when you came down to the
rent to rent training like a few months
ago what happened what was your
experience and what was the result um to
be honest was mind-blowing having
other academy members and like-minded
people around it just sort of
upslifts your spirit to you know be in
property and make this be successful so
definitely brought my morale quite quite
quite high up and i was like my wife was
like if you i'm fully supporting you in
this you know we're on the academy now
let's make it happen yeah and
after that no well before i joined the
academy from the renter and we're like
you know we're going to book ourselves
onto the deal selling uh master class
and then we're going to see how it goes
from there but you know the energy you
will fill in from being around you so
what actually happened on the program
because energy is one thing it's
important to be motivated but at the
same time you've got to actually get
results and you've got to get proper
training and get knowledge so what
actually happened on the program that
was so significant
i think it was just captivating the way
you were coming across as a property
trainer yes and what results did you get
i found my first deal bites upon my
first deal so motivation being
captivated being in the right
environment that's all great stuff yes
but the reason that people do that the
thing that people want is to actually
get a deal exactly so tell me how you
found the deal what did you do exactly
so that people listening can follow into
the exact actually exactly what you
what i saw you doing or i went on to
gumtree right and i looked i i clicked
the button for private um london's only
what they adds up yeah and i found this
beautiful lady who had had up and it's
been there for a while and i was
thinking to myself well it's been there
for a while why is in the rented house
you know so message her directly you
know on gumtree she then replied to me
and we organized the viewing i obviously
told her i introduced myself you know
kind of um ask her if she was available
and then yeah we set up a um a viewing
so you're just interested i went on gum
treatment
because before that i was trying right
move i was bringing agents and nothing
seemed to sort of click you know so
in terms of i had one i knew for sure
yeah that yeah i was going to go viewing
and potentially this could actually
secure my first deal so i went on gum
she tried gum tree method which i saw
you do and it was just you know i was
like if someone's putting it out there
there's must be some truth behind it
like it can work yeah see i went on
gumtree took the private um setting to
find private landlords only or not as
the legends got a view in booked in and
i went to see a
yes so the property what was it
it was a two bed house
semi sort of end of terrace um in sort
of the city center of
chippenham of chipping them so quite a
nice area quite a nice area
um i hardly know some that did some due
diligence on the area to see the demand
for people wanting rooms versus the
demand for um rooms available yes and i
remember you know on one of your
training you said to compare the ratios
and make sure you know it's sort of a
three to one yeah yeah yeah and then it
worked quite well in that area as well
so you were going to be renting this
property as a single let family home and
then you were doing your research at the
hmi boot camp about could you rent this
out on a room by room basis is that
correct exactly okay so how much rent
did she want and how much rent did you
end up paying
so she wanted a thousand two hundred
pounds a month yes i managed to bring
her down to one one nice and then she
she wouldn't budge below that um you
know and i was like you know at the end
of the day
when i run the numbers i remember you
always said if the deals thought of not
bringing you 500 profit and and above
you shouldn't really go into it so i was
like run the numbers after expenses
after everything i was making 560. right
on this particular rendering first one
and i was like it isn't really much but
at least i can start building a
reputation right you know building sort
of
a good credibility yeah with with
landlords exactly and initially she did
give me a difficult time saying yes you
know it wasn't that she said directly no
but she didn't give a difficult time to
come to an agreement with me because
obviously my company had only just been
open i didn't have any referencing to go
off you know i was only i was acting as
a guarantor for my for my business if
you know what i mean yeah just from
being in the army and that's all really
hard to go off and just being genuinely
you know honest with her not leaving
anything not cutting around the bush not
leaving anything out being open and
genuine if i'm lying i don't know this
is the business idea this is what i i'm
here to offer you you know this is how
we can come into some long-term uh
partnership love it and we both can help
each other out
so you're paying her a flat rent of
11.50 how much are you ready
1100 how much are you renting the
property out for so
what i did obviously again from
attending your courses i learned the
idea of sort of looking for properties
where you can
improve the value yeah so the property
had two beds two reception rooms
so what i did was i turned one of the
reception room into a bedroom to make it
a free bed
and i kept the reception room as a
communal area because of the size of the
room wasn't allowing for me to send that
other reception room into another
bedroom yeah so i kept it just to make
sure i was doing it correct
and then i managed to just add a little
partition wall a little door frame on
the door i did a little bit of a
refrigerator she i told her about and
she was happy for me to carry carry out
that and um yeah i managed to get into a
free bed where i had free tenants in not
just two
and i will manage to get each room at 6
50 and the largest room was 700. okay so
you're getting what like around about
two thousand a month and two thousand
pounds in all revenue and then you're
paying her eleven fifty eleven fifty um
bills are coming up to three forty yeah
and then again in five sixty five fifty
seven okay so it's not like a great
money maker it's not but um you know
it's five six hundred pound a month for
coming in how much did you have to spend
on like the refurb and all that stuff so
in all everything cost me about three
five three thousand five hundred yeah
and that's for absolutely everything
that's for the furnishings somebody they
did have built-in appliances already in
that property so and obviously the beds
and you know the soft functions and
stuff had to get that and then the
refurb was only 600. how do you work out
if a rent to rent is a good deal or not
how do you because sometimes if you're
having to do a small refurb maybe you're
having to put down upfront deposit rents
and then you're only making a small
monthly profit where's the cut off line
is there a formula so obviously from you
know doing your course and learning um i
normally tend to go off uh
a six month sort of time frame where
from my profits what i've invested if i
can pay back or the house can generate
me enough money to pay back within six
months i would say that's a that's a a
good benefit a good aspect where you can
get that property on invest in it and
you know after six months you paid all
your investments and then you can start
profiting properly from it if you know
what i mean so looking at the figures
and then calculating obviously with the
um
the expenses being taken away from the
revenues can generate um yeah i i
decided
that would be a feasible and you've
since you've since duplicated this
you've now become financially free
through the rent to rent strategy so
congratulations thank you samuel and um
and and and you've quit your job now
yeah talk to me about that because i
know you're in the army and that was
like a huge burden it was talk to me
about
getting out of that and giving you know
to be honest um my wife has been asking
me to live ever since
a couple years ago and a couple days ago
a couple years a couple of years ago
like maybe four or five years six years
ago yeah she she brought the idea of
living and
i just kept you know
prolonging it
i'm not really thinking that yeah
there's other bigger and better ideas
and opportunities out there and then
from 2019 she brought in their property
towards towards the table and like we
should really get into this and then
covet hit and then come 2021 when things
were a bit more relaxed i was like you
know what babe i think you're right
let's get full on to property so we
booked ourselves on some crash courses
yeah and then all sort of you know just
started spiraling upwards from there to
the point when i had this first rent to
rent we had we already had a property we
bought six and three four years ago
which we were just renting out as a
single that we didn't have any idea of
on knowledge of property and then
obviously being on the academy having
the support around having even evans you
know checking up on me and
and and giving me that one-on-one you
know mentor ship yeah it was
mind-blowing of knowing that i could
actually use my property
turn it into essay and
benefit you know so much financially
from it right so that's another thing
that you did right yeah that's another
thing i didn't change your property talk
to me about that and always
so
it was a bit mind-blowing because
when i spoke to events about having this
property and events is like you know why
haven't you done it as an essay and why
haven't you and i was like you know
you're actually right after obviously
after doing the rent-run service
accommodation course i learned so much
about
using the property of different
strategies to make you know loads of
money of it and i was like
i'm gonna turn it into an essay you know
first thing i did was i took a picture
of the front of the house set up an
airbnb um account and put it up there
and had bookings come in right
so that was even before i have had it
set up as an essay so i was like wow
this area really works because bookends
keep coming in and you know yeah and
i i reached a point where i was like you
know i need to give notice to the
tenants and because i was a good tenant
you know nice little family i didn't
want to really rush them out of the
house but at the end of the day you know
you have to sort of use what you have
yeah to your advantage so
give them no they're getting three
months notice they don't find another
place you know and then they moved out
only in february this year end of
february right so i got the keys back
first of match and i told the wife i
want this property to be up and running
for first of april
so
because with the property is free enough
hours away from where we live currently
every weekend would go up with the boys
and would start little jobs you know
wife wanted to do a little bit of a
refurb take out all the carpet replace
it with with laminate wood um do up the
the family bathroom because it wasn't
properly tiled
um
and pinned the whole house over yeah and
i wanted that done for first of april
and we're only going up every weekend so
every two days
you know a week
and towards the end of march i think it
was around the 25th or 26th or thursday
a booking came in for the whole of april
whole of me
about six thousand something pounds one
booking for two months one booking and i
was like is this is this a universe tell
me something here because i've asked for
it okay what hasn't been done yeah
flooring wasn't fully laid out bathroom
wasn't done house wasn't painted
and i was telling myself can i make this
is this possible can i make this happen
within two days cause i only had two
days from the first day
the the tenth the guests were moving in
the following monday
you know
and i decided you know what my wife was
a bit sketchy should we take this
pokemon and we can't really fulfill you
know what we're asking for and i was
like nah i'm very optimistic guy and you
know when i put my set my mind on
something i always wonderful you know
see through so i had a colleague of mine
who's done some property refurbishing
before he works with me in the army he's
luckily his brother was up here with him
and decided to help me out free of
charge oh no so we both went up it was
four of us my wife man we left the boys
at home if you know her carer because
we're like you're not coming office this
time we gotta be focused and literally
from saturday night to monday night i
didn't sleep
you know the time from monday afternoon
i mean and we worked we worked our you
know we worked really hard getting all
the flooring done did all the flooring
painted the house got all the finishing
two days ikea yeah a facebook
marketplace and yeah the guests moved in
on the monday and they were really happy
that's amazing and we got it done and i
was like you know this is a blessing and
have you got more bookings coming in and
i've got more bookings coming i've got a
10-man booking now i'm working on who's
going to bring about 46 000 pounds wow
if it does you know pull through i'm
working on but i've got a little
bookings i've got some bookings for
august already for june july now
actually i'm booking coming this morning
nice so it's really really picking up
how much was that property making you
profit before you did that 200 pounds
200 pounds a month single it was paying
his mortgage off that's the thing man i
was only making 200 pounds and i i was
thinking that's all right you know 200
pounds i'm not doing anything how much
is it making now a month two thousand
pounds profits wow just on that one deal
yep so the first deal i made well every
month two for april 2000 pounds for me
it'll be 2000 pounds yeah and then come
for june my intention is to have it
fully booked that's the thing
little tweaks in property like you
already had that property was making you
200 pounds
you've 10xed it yeah you've obviously
now in a position where you can
comfortably leave the army how does it
feel to be able to leave the army
absolutely amazing absolutely amazing
and if i knew better if i knew what i
know now a couple years ago out of
listening to my wife and left ages ago
yeah you know i was just thinking about
it now i'm not gonna say that i regret
the decision but
i didn't know what i knew now back in
the you know four years ago yeah so i'm
quite happy that i've gone i was given
the opportunity to take on the
information get the knowledge done and
now i know what i know now to move
forward and just make things you know
go up and up and up now and where are
you from where are you from originally
originally born and raised in salusia in
the caribbean right yeah
that's why we connected to evans exactly
me and evans connected straight away and
i was from one of the crash courses i
attended he actually saw me and came up
to me and then i was like yeah i
remember you you know you were two years
below me in school in high school you
know he was one of those that would be
envy on me and stuff and then i was like
well now i'm looking up to you now you
know because hey i want to be exactly
how you know where you are
in this journey so we yeah we obviously
got in contact we changed numbers and
ever since we've been in frequent
contact with each other what made you
and your wife decided to join the
academy
so i mean evans was definitely a fact in
it but obviously you ultimately you know
was
just the energy brought to it and yeah
and the fact that you've
you know you were so
you were so just real with the whole
aspect of it whereas we've been on other
property trainers um courses before as
well
and it was nothing compared to you know
the environment and
and what we felt working with you yeah
you know so
joining the academy i mean
initially we wanted both of us to go on
it but my wife said you know i would
just pay for me for me only
and
she might fully support you know when
when i want to do something or if i want
to you know go into it and she was like
you really see you know this is
something that we can do together are
you going to give it your all she's
going to support me 100 and i was like
yeah evans was talking to me about it he
was the one that actually booked us on
yeah and you know and i believed in him
one thing one thing that
i got in the in the academy was the
trust aspect you know yeah we come to to
trust each other to a point where yeah
we're gonna put we're gonna put our
actions in but we trust the knowledge
we've given which was the support we've
given that yeah this can work you know
so that was the biggest factor to want
to be honest you know the relationship
that was built in short a short period
of time even if i had known evidence
from before but
um you can see it's genuine you know
it's not something where someone's just
trying to tell you something and forget
about your after and and that's it you
know and leave you to just crumble if
you if you if you find you're not
getting any results it was what's your
strongest reason for wanting to do this
what i mean it sounded like you had to
work really hard on that on that one
deal what's the motivation what's the
drive it's my family to be honest yeah
who we can hear very loudly yeah my
little boy's back
who's attached to you now you start
being more at home more yeah and he was
actually born during kovit he was born
in january 2020 and you know obviously
we all know those are those who have
kids that they're not they're not easy
to maintain they're they're actually a
financial you know yeah this is your
life yeah whether you like to think of
it like that or not but i was like hey
at the end of the day i still want to
grow my family
and i want to be able to do it
comfortably financially and not have to
worry about you know what's going on
where's the money going to come from to
pay this
and you know just just being a good
stress-free you know sort of mind frame
with my family and
financially with knowing that we have
you know secured monies coming in from
property yeah to to to give us the
lifestyle we want
what would you advise somebody watching
this that's wanting to follow in your
footsteps
i would say
take on the knowledge because knowledge
is power knowledge is key
um
mindset is a big one aspect of well you
know knowing um investing in your own
personal development and growth is a big
one because if you have all the
knowledge and your mindset isn't right
it's not going to work yes i've realized
that you know if certain people that's
come to me and ask me certain you know
advice on things obviously i've posted
stuff in the academy so they've seen my
progress
but yeah i would say
have you need to get the knowledge
because knowledge is you know you need
to be educated if what you're doing and
you need to have a you need to have the
right mindset where
when because in property
people who always tell you no more than
they tell you yes you need to be able to
be comfortable accepting the nose and
seeing it as an a step closer to the yes
yeah once you once you have your mindset
right and you have the knowledge
all you need that's all you need and the
next step is just going out there and
taking the action steps
but with the mindset you will be able to
go out and do it
you know amazing and implement the
knowledge you've learned and you will
get that yes it's just be patient
everybody's journey is different you
know don't think and don't feel um
downgraded by seeing other people's
success faster than you know what you
would think for yourself just take your
time be patient and keep going and don't
stop what do you prefer
rent to hmo or rent to service
accommodation because you've done
service accommodation really i'm not i
think so my next step is obviously i
told you we're looking at sort of going
into well we're looking at pulling some
money out of the property um possibly
investing in some um cheap auction
properties option housing
to you know do them up i look forward to
helping you with that yeah 100 but um
i think my next step is to get two more
entrants and two more s's yeah before i
think i need to obviously hire some
employees to help me out because i'm
doing everything on my own you know yeah
every single thing on my own right now
and you haven't even left the army yet
so you're doing that on your top i'm
doing it on tour i mean being i don't
really do much army work to say
because my my my guy my my um employ my
um supervisors and stuff in the army
have given me you know the liberty to
try and
get myself secured properly financially
for when i actually when they stop
paying me so yeah give me that liberty
which is a good thing but i still tend
to you know report if i'm needed yeah
certain duties and stuff yes so many
people ask me
how do i get started what's the first
steps
i'm just starting out what would you
say um if you're just starting out i
would say you need to put yourself out
there you know you need to at least let
people know what you're doing yeah and
that could be you know just from little
posts on social media or you know little
letters you could send to potential
landlords from just finding the details
on on um the government website
you know um
landlord registry you know just putting
yourself out there you know telling
people what you do when you meet people
you know in a supermarket or something
you know just let them know what you do
if they're if they're if they're on the
conversation with you and that's one
thing i'm even still trying to develop
myself into putting myself out there
more because you know everyone has
different personalities and some people
uh what i find
they stay in a shadow from the social
media aspect
whereas they could it could be that
they're not saying why they should put
themselves out there and everyone's you
know know what they're doing and do it
secretly if you know what i mean yeah
but there's there's more benefits i mean
from putting yourself out there to just
staying in the shadows and some people
nesting to cross that gap and knowing
you know let people know what you're
doing tell the world that you're
properly invested yeah yeah what are you
doing so that is one of the things i am
actually you know working on to improve
myself on because when i met evans
everyone was like you know i don't see
you on instagram i tell you i tell them
i didn't even have instagram you know um
and it's just from the upbringing of you
know not being too much on social media
it's it's not something that's good you
know something that's positive but it is
actually positive and good if you're
doing it you know well that's how i
everybody that's how evans blew up when
we did our documentary together yeah and
he just had over half a million views
and it's really helped his personal
brand exactly so so that is what i would
advise people let people know what
you're doing you know get your brand out
there and then you know everything will
start coming together love it what's
been the most challenging point then
over the last sort of year or two of
doing property what was there a point
when you wanted to quit
100 there was a point
um
i think it's just trying to balance
everything out you know because i have
two boys i have my wife at home and
initially my wife wasn't working i don't
remember when the deal said in um course
where we did the freedom intensive yeah
she was she was out of a job you know i
was the only one sort of working from
the army still and he was trying to
juggle a lot of things at once thinking
you know if i don't get this property
stuff rolling what's going to happen
financially and yeah it was a lot of
decisions where i was like do i just try
and you know apply for another job and
not you know worry about property
because obviously my wife went for a bit
of a mental you know um
state of of depression right and i had
to obviously support her through that
you know because i didn't know they were
team so i had to go for all that and
still be motivated to actually go out
and do viewings and get property deals
secured because i knew and i saw the
light of property can be a life-changing
game for any family anyone that's
struggling financially anyone that you
know wants to live the nine to five so
definitely going for that transition of
my wife not having a job obviously i
know that i'm going to be on there i'm
soon out of a job
balancing
you know work and also having the kids
at home because i look after the kids
you know
most of the time
um together with my wife as well but
yeah that was very difficult a lot of
people say
a lot of people say i haven't got time
to do property i've got my job my kids
my this my that i haven't got time but
actually that's the very reason that
they should do property
because they've got no time and if they
carry on just running on the rat race of
life they're going to end up being
retired and realizing maybe they've
wasted their life exactly and and
people say they haven't got time but
there's a lot of another as me and my
wife we're always going to deep
discussions and one of them was the time
we have as human beings every day 24
hours it's it's given to each human
being individually the same yeah it's
only how you utilize it and if you look
at you break down 24 hours 24 hour day
to obviously sleeping eating you know
working you still have time left over
right you still have time left over and
you know it's it's just using that time
you have left left over scheduling it
you know prioritizing it properly and it
doesn't take long to get deals no like
everybody gets their first deal not
everybody but a lot of people get their
first deal when they're actually at the
course because they're taking the right
kind of action if you pick up the phone
and just go on gumtree and just start
calling landlords saying the right thing
it could be half an hour before you land
your first deal
so most people they spend all their
spare time thinking about property
scrolling on rightmove creating
spreadsheets thinking tricking
themselves that they're working really
hard but they're not taking the right
kind of action exactly
what was that what was the moment when
you decided you were going to quit the
army to be honest it was when my wife
went through sort of a mental this
depression state
i was like i think that's enough because
i mean nothing against the email i
enjoyed in my career i loved it but the
army does make you deploy a lot away
from home and from your family yeah and
you know that could have a gen an effect
on anyone to be honest you know mentally
if they have to work and look after kids
and you're just away working and living
your life you know yeah so
from that point that was where i was
like yeah enough is enough
time to move on time to explore property
and explore the options out there and
time to you know make a better living
for my family so i decided it's going to
leave the army because sometimes i
deploy this week come back home i deploy
again next week last minute
and you know there's no preparation
sometimes in place
to to help my partner maybe she is if
she has something to do or what not so
it was a lot and i was like yeah call
call it quits the good thing about when
you when you're in the army you sign off
you have a whole yeah they give you only
every settlement to sort yourself out
the courses you know get yourself
prepared for cv street so i had that
whole year from last year june i signed
off
um
just to get myself ready yeah obviously
like i said i was still being called in
to do work with the army as well
and then slowly when do you completely
finish as into the army yes so 10th of
june next is my last day 10th of june
next year no no sorry 10 40 next month
oh next month that's better i'm not not
next more april's still so yeah
basically
is your wife a lot happier now oh she's
over the moon really are you a lot
happier now 100
that's amazing like i told you what i
know now if i if i knew it four or five
years ago my wife was telling me leave
the army i'd have done it yeah ages ago
you know it's just
i think i was quite comfortable in the
army knowing you know pay was guaranteed
i had the security of having a monthly
salary coming every month i had army
housing which was you know i was paying
like 200 pounds for rent you know it was
heavily subsidized and stuff so this
benefits from the army make you get
quite comfortably under how did you
justify doing the academy because the
academy is a big investment oh yeah oh
yeah so how did you justify that
well
i mean obviously going off other academy
members results to start with um
going off evidence in particular you
know my solution brother yeah
and
just the support that was going to be
given from the academy obviously you
have access to all the other courses you
have access to everything you need
pretty much yeah you know what more
could you ask for and i mean at the end
of the day it's it isn't a a big
investment for some people
but
you can make that money back yeah in no
time right if you put the action steps
in and you've you know you've
implemented the different strategies
that you've been taught from the academy
yeah you know you can make an and that
was that's that is one of the driving
aspects i was telling my because we
weren't we were still 50 50 even
speaking to evans and i was like you
know what babe i think i can make this
work yeah and i'm and i was 100
made up my mind you know like yeah i can
make this work we're going to join the
academy and we're going to get that that
initial investment paid off in no time
yeah and at least within the year of
being on the academy you know and yeah
and it's being paid off right now as we
speak so hey that was the driving
factors joining the academy i was like
you know and and it's it's it's been
reward it's been rewarding because like
i told you i've been in constant contact
with evans who signed me up you know
it's not like he's just left me and not
even called me after i joined the
academy he's con he's been contacting me
he's been checking up on me he's been
you know if i need any help obviously we
have the academy group as well we can
put questions we have the mentoring
calls so it's just
it's just having all these things around
you
knowing this is not an investment where
you just put money down and you just get
left alone and yeah there's no help or
no support at the end of the tunnel you
have that yeah absolutely and it's
important as well because people people
need that support people do people do
people do because like i said everyone's
different some people may get a couple
no's or and feel like wow even if you
know people said do this and do that it
hasn't worked out and then people just
stopped there and sometimes just quit
and revert back to what they were doing
before yeah because they know they don't
know any better you know it's a big
thing i believe in manifestation as well
because every night every morning when i
wake up i just envision how i want my
life to be yeah and i keep doing that
and keep doing that and slowly but
surely it is it's coming there you know
without me actually knowing it would
happen
so definitely the power manifestation
the power of just using your your mind
is so powerful
and everybody has that that
advantage and that asset to their
disposal you just got to use it yeah
well you deserve every success thanks
samuel thanks so much appreciate that
and appreciate it you know
the support you've given me obviously
and your mentor and your guy you know
people i work on them if you'll give me
as well it couldn't be more happier than
that and like i said up from up from now
it's only going better it's going to get
better and better and hey
[Music]
you